le chanvre on le connaît pour son huile
on ne connaît pour ses graines mais dans
l'oise canadiens une nouvelle industrie
axée sur la fibre de chanvre un matériau
extrêmement polyvalent est en train de
voir le jour et les superficies
consacrées à cette culture sont en
pleine expansion
au sud de calgary où les vastes contrées
des prairies rencontre les rocheuses
road le nir cultive du chanvre sur 400
hectares il est l'un des plus importants
producteurs de chanvre en alberta
lorsqu'il s'est lancé dans la culture de
cette plante il y a dix ans c'était
surtout pour vendre son gré très
recherché à l'époque plus de fermiers
cultivent et de la graine de chambre
donc son prix est très avantageux
à l'époque elle se vendait 1 dans la
libre c'était 30% plus élevé que mes
autres cultures donc plutôt que de
brûler comme d'autres fermiers sa paille
de chanvre après les récoltes
ils entreposent sursitaire dans l'espoir
qu'il puisse un jour trouvé preneur tout
ça c'est sortie demain moissonneuses
batteuses au cours des dix dernières
années et nous avons six autres piles
comme celle ci gray a été vendu mais
nous gardons la paille à la ferme
en attendant le bon client mais au cours
des prochains mois world venir pourrait
enfin avoir un acheteur pour toute cette
paille les opportunités c'est une
question de temps avant qu'on exploite
le reste du plan de chambre j'ai
entreposés mapaï juste un peu trop tôt à
jakarta
le chanvre serait l'une des plus
anciennes plantes cultivées sur la
planète récoltés pour son gré il y à des
millénaires la fibre de la plante sert
ensuite à fabriquer du papier
d'événements dévoile même du ciment pour
solidifier les ponts de pierre introduit
en amérique du nord route 7e siècle
le chanvre est cultivée à grande échelle
transformer entre autres en cordage pour
les navires
et louis ford s'en sert même dans la
carrosserie d'une voiture se vantant de
sa solidité
mais à partir de 1970 la culture du
chanvre est interdite partout sur le
continent en raison de son lien de
parenté avec son fusil
le cannabis puis en 1998 le chanvre fait
son retour
d'abord au canada
son grain suscite beaucoup d'intérêt en
raison de sa valeur nutritive
la production de la plante augmentent
presque chaque année pour atteindre
sommet de 57 milles hectares semés en
2010 est de plus en plus de fermiers se
sont mis à cultiver du chanvre ce qui
fait chuter le prix à 90 5 à 81 cents la
livre
mais entre temps avait crevé l'un
alberta des chercheurs tentent de
redorer le blason du chanvre pas
supervise la ferme expérimentale chez
innotech un institut provincial de
recherche
on utilise cette fibre pour fabriquer
toutes sortes de choses
alors pourquoi cette industrie n'a pas
été développée au canada
on en revient encore au paradoxe de
l'oeuf et de la poule les fermiers ne
s'intéressait pas à la paille de chanvre
parce qu'il n'y avait pas d'acheteur et
personne n'achetait la paille parce que
les fermiers n'en produisait pas sur ces
parcelles ont créé des variétés de
chanvre adaptées aux climats des
prairies et qui produisent beaucoup de
fibres
voici une variété cultivée pour le grain
ne mesure qu environ un mètre derrière
moi vous voyez l'un de nos variétés
cultivées surtout pour la fibre elle
mesure environ 4 m donc elle produit
beaucoup plus de biomasse
on cherche aussi des variétés qui se
prête bien à la décortication le
processus qui permet de séparer les
longues fibres de la chaîne vote les
longues fibres ici ce sont les fibres 2
les corses à l'extérieur de la tige et
ça c'est la chaîne votes
les fibres courtes à l'intérieur de la
tige vous voyez je viens de décortiquer
ces tiges
et knotek fait construire la première
usine de décorticage sion de chanvre au
pays
la paille est d'abord couper ensuite
déchiquetés et teillé
les deux parties de la tige sont ainsi
décortiqués
les longues fibres finissent par sortir
d'un côté la chaîne votes de l'autre
le processus de décortication est la
pierre angulaire de la chaîne de
transformation de la fibre de chanvre
innotech vend ensuite sa fibre brut aux
entreprises qui s'intéressent au chanvre
sauveur abus on veut parler ce père
ainsi initié la création d'une industrie
totalement nouvelle
près de la ville de drayton valley
l'entrepreneur d'al-magrun fond d'une
usine de transformation de produits
fabriqués avec de la fibre naturelle
la fibre de chambrée forte longue et
polyvalente
c'est de loin la meilleure des fibres
naturelles disponibles ici en alberta
elle peut pousser de 6 pouces par jour
et on peut la récoltés chaque année en
comparaison une fibre de bois peut
prendre jusqu'à 80 ans avant d'atteindre
sa maturité
l'entreprise développe toutes sortes de
produits à base de fibres et de résine
de chanvre
nous avons créé des panneaux de
portières de voiture voici une rame de
kayak planche à roulettes
nous avons aussi créé ce revêtement
extérieur le compostables à la fin de
son cycle de vie
il y a des milliers de possibilités
il s'arrête sur un article produite à
grande échelle
des cubes pour la culture de végétaux
destinés aux particuliers et auxerre
commercial
nous avons créé un substrat de
croissance compaq qui remplace le
terreau nous misons maintenant sur ce
substrat pour développer notre
entreprise
le produit se vend comme des petits
pains chauds
à un tel point que l' usine de
décorticage sion dénotait qu avait
greville ne peut leur fournir assez de
fibres
il doit donc importer sa fibre d'europe
toutes les pièces doivent être en place
si on veut développer aussi une
véritable industrie
mais ils espèrent pouvoir acheter
bientôt de la fée brut iv dans les
champs des fermiers canadiens
une usine de décorticage sion privé est
en chantier au nord-est d'edmonton qui
pourra transformer 10 tonnes de chanvre
par heure la fibre produite ici sera
vendu aux entreprises locales
d'autres propose de décortiquer le
chanvre autrement
nature of our technology effectué au
moment de notre visite
la mise au point d'un système de
décortication portatif
la qualité n'est pas très bonne
y'a trop de chènevotte dans ce produit
ont vu de meilleure séparation des
fibres ça fait partie du processus
d'optimisation
il espère louer ces unité portative aux
fermiers qui pourront décortiquer eux
mêmes le chanvre pourquoi ne pas
décentraliser la décortication ça peut
se faire à la ferme
entre-temps en banlieue de calgary
l'entreprise just by you fabre
s'intéresse à la chaîne votes les
petites fibres qui forment la moelle du
plan de chanvre
mélanger avec de la chaux la chaîne
votes et placés dans des moules puis
chauffé à haute température
résultat des blocs de construction qui
ressemblent à des pièces de lego cessé
en les uns dans les autres pour former
les murs de bâtiments selon le fondateur
macwrite freud ce matériau aurait les
mêmes qualités que la pierre calcaire
solide durable est en soi un excellent
isolant
c'est une structure près solide qui les
estivants de 480 kilomètres à l'heure
c'est à dire un ouragan ou une tornade
un produit qui résiste au choc puis aux
flammes
il a une et dix de résistance au feu de
deux heures voici un mélange de chanvre
et de chaux
vous voyez comme ça tourne rouge
s'approche et 2000 degrés assez pour
faire fondre du métal non rien du tout
touché si vous même
quelques maisons entières ont déjà été
construites avec ses blocs l'intérêt
grandissant pour des bâtiments verts s7
l'entreprise a misé le tout pour le tout
elle compte ouvrir en 2021 sa propre
usine de décorticage sion de chance
si tous semblent se bousculer dans
l'industrie de la fibre de chanvre au
pays c'est qu'il y aurait une véritable
course contre la montre la culture du
chanvre monte en flèche aux états unis
depuis que la plante a été réintroduite
en 2014
si on veut créer une industrie ici il
faut agir maintenant nos investisseurs
américains nous disent que la fibre de
chambre suscite beaucoup d'intérêt chez
eux
nous avons plus de temps pour bien me
positionner pour créer des emplois et
pour profiter des retombées d'une telle
industrie
on peut tout perdre ou tout gagné dans
la prochaine année
je m'excuse chose certaine ce n'est pas
la matière première qui manquent
on prévoit que les fermiers canadiens
doubleront leur hectares semés en
chanvre en 2020 cela s'explique surtout
par le marché émergent des huiles de
cannabis violent et les nouvelles
variétés de chanvre permettent de
récolter à la fois le grain la fibre et
l'huile de cbd
je n'ai aucune autre culture comme
celle-ci fax le nain tune en vente la
graine de blé dur c'est pareil tout
comme les lentilles alors que le chambre
te donne trois sources de revenus pour
les producteurs comme voir devenir tous
les espoirs sont permis avec le chanvre
devrait être ma principale source de
revenus pour les prochaines années